harry belafonte to my mind one of the
most inspiring aspects of your life is
the way that you have used your time
your talent and your treasure to change
the world and to make it better in my
view that makes you one of the greatest
philanthropist do you agree with the way
with that term when we refer to you well
as you describe how I've used my life
there is truth to that i didn't set out
to be a philanthropist and work at
philanthropy for me what i did and what
I do is just a part of the the more
fundamental aspects of one's humanity I
think we should all be philanthropists
or all in philanthropy I think this part
of the generosity of the human spirit
the human soul how did you come to that
how did you come to that belief by
ducking philanthropists icated that out
of out of social experience I was born
into poverty and poverty dictated the
way in which I would meet the challenges
of life and my mother was also a victim
of poverty and I watch what she did with
nobility and with dignity the way in
which he met the challenges hugely
influenced my take on what I should be
doing with my life when I came of age
and was able to make my decisions and
court uncharted been tough decisions at
the time in which you came of age which
was some turbulent times how did you get
involved for example with market with
the king and the civil rights movement I
mean you had a career you were you were
launching yourself as one of the biggest
start if not the biggest star in music
and and and on the screen but this must
have been challenging for you
well all of it is challenging but when I
first became aware of the good fortune
that was being put for me the great
question for me is what do I do with
with this power what do I do with this
inflow of influence and resources and
the capacity to have people at least
pause long enough to hear what you have
to say and it became quite evident based
upon role models and other social
experiences that to serve the cause of
justice which was my main goal the
biggest thing about poverty for me was
the injustice of it the crushing human
humiliating aspects of daily life
begging your way through each each
encounter and that seemed to me to be
quite any inhumane my mother's
construction him he was never go to bed
at night knowing that there was
something I could have done to fight
injustice and never engaged myself and
that in that confrontation so from early
on I understood where have I saw
injustice my commitment my task was to
resist it to challenge it and to change
it no matter how minimal the event might
appear to be or how large it might how
Lord would reveal itself and that became
a practice became a pattern became a
habit so when I made a lot of Mike
outside of the immediate needs to
extricate myself from debt and to put my
family into some place of a more
balanced social experience the rest
about how do you change the universe and
how do you use your resources your
talent the money the influence
personality or DNA how do you put it all
into the pot and get on with trying to
make the world a better place than the
way in which you found it and that was
just my life I didn't challenge it I was
challenged but each time I stepped to
the plate and people asked for my
services or indicated and interest in my
services I easily gave it because I
became committed to their cause to the
cause you all should have been and are
still committed to